Mais ils n'ont plus besoin de se battre
pour les fondamentaux de la démocratie,
car ils ont dépassé cette étape.
Je crois qu'en 2016,
cette géographie hiérarchique a volé en éclats.
Notre monde ne suit plus le modèle dualiste
imaginé par l'esprit académique. S'il a jamais existé.
A présent, nous savons que l'histoire n'évolue pas nécessairement vers l'avant.
Parfois, elle fait des cercles
ou retourne en arrière.
Des générations peuvent répéter les erreurs
que leurs grands-parents ont commises.
Nous savons ainsi qu'il n'y a pas
des pays solides par opposition à des pays liquides.
En fait, nous vivons tous dans des temps liquides,
ainsi que nous l'a appris Zygmunt Bauman.
Bauman avait aussi une autre définition de notre ère.
Il disait que nous allions tous marcher vers des sables mouvants.
Si c'est le cas,
je crois que ça devrait nous concerner davantage nous les femmes, que les hommes.
Car quand les sociétés régressent vers l'autoritarisme,
le nationalisme ou le fanatisme religieux,
les femmes ont beaucoup plus à perdre.
C'est pour cette raison que ceci doit forcément être un moment vital
non seulement pour l'activisme mondial,
mais pour la solidarité mondiale entre femmes, à mon avis.
(Applaudissements)
Permettez-moi de vous faire une petite confession.
Jusqu'il y a peu, quand je participais à une conférence internationale,
je faisais souvent partie de ces orateurs déprimants.
(Rires)
On a brisé nos rêves de démocratie et de coexistence en Turquie.
J'en suis le témoin.
Ça s'est passé progressivement mais à une vitesse incroyable.
Avec les années qui passaient, j'étais plutôt démoralisée.
A ces festivals, il y avait d'autres écrivains lugubres,
venus d'Égypte, du Nigeria, du Pakistan,
du Bangladesh, des Philipines, de Chine, du Vénézuela ou de Russie.
On se souriait avec empathie,
avec la camaraderie des maudits.
(Rires)
On aurait pu nous surnommer les CIEAD.
Club International des Écrivains Anxieux et Déprimés.
(Rires)
Mais les choses ont commencé à changer
et notre club est devenu plus populaire.
On a accueilli des nouveaux membres.
Je me souviens --
(Rires)
je me souviens que des écrivains et poètes grecs nous ont rejoints en premier.
Ensuite, ceux de Hongrie et de Pologne sont montés à bord.
Après eux, et c'est curieux, des écrivains d'Autriche, de Hollande et de France.
Encore après, ceux d'Angleterre, où je vis, ma maison,
et enfin, des États-Unis.
Brusquement, nous étions nombreux
à ressentir de l'inquiétude au sujet du destin de nos nations
et de l'avenir de notre monde.
Nous sommes sans doute encore plus nombreux
à nous sentir étrangers dans notre propre pays.
Ensuite, une chose bizarre a eu lieu.
Ceux parmi nous qui étaient dépressifs depuis longtemps
ont commencé à se sentir moins déprimés
alors que les nouveaux, qui n'étaient pas habitués à ce sentiment,
se sentaient beaucoup plus déprimés.
(Rires)
Il n'était pas rare de voir des écrivains du Bangladesh, de Turquie ou d'Égypte
tenter de consoler leurs collègues
de l'Angleterre du Brexit ou des États-Unis post-élection.
(Rires)
Plaisanterie à part,
je pense que notre monde est rempli de défis inédits.
Ils sont accompagnés par des répercussions émotionnelles
à cause de la vélocité du changement.
Car beaucoup de personnes veulent ralentir
et quand il y a trop d'inconnues,
les gens recherchent désespérément la familiarité.
Quand tout devient trop confus,
beaucoup de gens nourrissent un désir ardent de simplicité.
C'est un carrefour très dangereux
car c'est là précisément que les démagogues entrent en jeu.
Le démagogue comprend comment fonctionnent les sentiments collectifs
et comment il, c'est souvent un il, peut en tirer profit.
Il nous dit que nous avons tous notre place dans notre tribu,
que nous serons plus en sécurité entourés de ceux qui nous ressemblent.
Les démagogues adoptent toutes les tailles, toutes les formes.
Il peut être un dirigeant excentrique d'un parti politique marginal,
quelque part en Europe,
un imam extrémiste islamiste prêchant dogme et haine
ou un suprémaciste blanc, adorateur avoué du nazisme, ailleurs.
Toutes ces personnes, aux premiers abords, semblent ne partager aucun lien.
Mais je crois qu'ils se nourrissent mutuellement,
qu'ils ont besoin l'un de l'autre.
Partout dans le monde,
en observant comment les démagogues parlent et inspirent des mouvements,
je pense qu'ils ont tous une caractéristique commune :
ils sont tous hostiles à la pluralité.
Ils ne savent pas gérer la multiplicité.
Adorno disait :
« L'intolérance à l’ambiguïté est la marque
d'une personnalité autoritaire. »
Mais je me demande :
que se passerait-il si cette même marque,
cette même intolérance à l'ambiguïté,
si c'était la marque de notre époque, de l'ère où nous vivons ?
Car où que je regarde, je vois les nuances s'estomper progressivement.
Dans les émissions télévisées, les animateurs sont anti-ceci ou cela,
en contradiction avec un orateur pro-quelque chose.
C'est bon pour l'audimat !
C'est encore mieux s'ils se crient dessus.
Même dans le monde académique, où l'intellect est censé être nourri,
on rencontre des chercheurs athées en concurrence avec des chercheurs théistes.
Mais il n'y a pas un véritable échange intellectuel
car il s'agit d'un conflit entre deux certitudes.
Les oppositions binaires sont présentes partout.
Lentement mais systématiquement,
on nous nie le droit d'être complexe.
Istamboul, Berlin, Nice, Paris, Bruxelles,
Dacca, Bagdad, Barcelone :
toutes ces villes ont vécu une horrible attaque terroriste, l'une après l'autre.
Quand on exprime sa douleur, quand on réagit contre la cruauté,
on attire des tas de réactions différentes,
de messages sur les réseaux sociaux.
Un d'entre eux est particulièrement troublant
tant il est répandu :
« Pourquoi ressentez-vous de la peine pour eux ?
Pourquoi être triste pour eux ?
Pourquoi pas être triste pour les civils au Yémen
ou les civils en Syrie ? »
Je crois que les gens qui écrivent de tels messages
ne comprennent pas
que nous pouvons être tristes et solidaires
avec les victimes du terrorisme
et de la violence au Moyen-Orient, en Europe,
en Asie, en Amérique, peu importe où,
de manière égale et simultanée.
Ils ne semblent pas comprendre
que nous n'avons pas besoin de choisir une douleur
à un endroit précis, parmi d'autres.
Mais c'est l'effet du tribalisme sur nous.
Il diminue notre esprit, c'est certain.
Il diminue aussi nos cœurs
à un point tel que nous devenons insensibles à la douleur des autres.
La triste vérité est que nous n'avons pas toujours été ainsi.
J'ai écrit un livre pour enfants en Turquie.
Quand le livre est paru, j'ai participé à des événements
dans des écoles primaires.
Ça m'a permis d'observer les enfants en Turquie.
C'était toujours fascinant de voir combien ils ont de l'empathie, de l'imagination
et de l'audace.
Ces enfants sont plus susceptibles de devenir des citoyens du monde
que des nationalistes à cet âge-là.
C'est merveilleux de les écouter
dire qu'ils veulent devenir poète ou écrivain.
Les filles sont aussi audacieuses que les garçons,
si pas davantage.
Ensuite, j'allais dans des écoles secondaires.
Là, la situation avait changé.
Plus personne ne souhaitait devenir écrivain.
Plus personne ne souhaitait écrire des essais.
Les filles étaient devenues timides,
prudentes, sur leurs gardes.
Elles hésitaient à parler en public
car nous leur avons appris,
c'est-à-dire la famille, l'école, la société,
nous leur avons appris à gommer leur personnalité.
À l'Est comme à l'Ouest,
nous sommes en train de perdre notre multiplicité
au sein de nos sociétés et de nous-même.
Parce que je suis née en Turquie, je sais que la perte de la diversité
est une perte majeure, vraiment majeure.
Aujourd'hui, ma patrie est devenue la plus grande prison au monde
pour les journalistes,
dépassant même le triste record de la Chine.
Je crois aussi que ce qui est arrivé en Turquie
peut survenir partout dans le monde.
Même ici.
Tout comme les pays solides s'avèrent être des illusions,
les identités uniques sont des illusions aussi.
Car nous possédons tous une multiplicité de voix en nous.
Le poète perse Hafiz
disait : « Vous portez dans votre âme tous les ingrédients nécessaires
pour transformer votre existence en bonheur.
Il vous suffit de mélanger ces ingrédients. »
Je pense que nous pouvons mélanger.
Je suis stambouliote,
mais je suis aussi attachée aux Balkans,
à la Mer Égée, la Méditerranée,
le Moyen-Orient, le Levant.
Je suis européenne de naissance et par choix,
de par les valeurs auxquelles je crois.
Les années ont fait de moi une Londonienne.
Je nourris une âme mondiale, je suis une citoyenne du monde,
une nomade, une passeuse d'histoires itinérante.
J'ai de multiples attaches, comme nous tous.
De multiples attaches signifient en fait des récits multiples.
Nous les écrivains, nous sommes toujours à la recherche d'un récit.
Mais nous sommes aussi curieux des silences,
des choses dont on ne peut pas parler,
les tabous politiques et culturels.
Nous sommes aussi curieux de nos propres silences.
J'ai toujours parlé et écrit à profusion
sur le droit des minorités, le droit des femmes,
le droit des LGBT.
Mais en réfléchissant à ma présentation TED,
je me suis aperçue
que je n'avais jamais eu le courage de dire en public
que je suis bisexuelle,
car je crains la médisance,
les stigmates, et le ridicule,
et la haine qui ne manqueront pas d'arriver.
Mais naturellement, personne ne peut rester silencieux
par crainte de la complexité.
(Applaudissements)
Bien que l'anxiété me soit familière
et que je vous parle du pouvoir des émotions,
je connais le pouvoir des émotions,
j'ai découvert avec le temps
que les émotions ne sont pas sans limite.
Vous comprenez ? Elles ont des limites.
Il arrive un moment,
un moment charnière ou un seuil,
où l'on n'en peut plus d'avoir peur,
où l'on n'en peut plus d'être anxieux.
Les individus ne sont sans doute pas les seuls.
Les nations aussi ont leurs propres moments charnières.
Au-delà de mes émotions,
je nourris cette conscience
que la fluidité ne concerne pas uniquement les genres et l'identité,
mais la vie elle-même.
Ils veulent nous diviser en tribus,
mais nous sommes reliés à travers les frontières.
Ils prêchent la certitude,
mais nous savons que la vie est faite de magie
et d’ambiguïté.
Ils aiment aussi les dualités,
mais nous sommes bien plus nuancés que cela.
Que pouvons-nous faire alors ?
Je propose de retourner aux sources,
aux couleurs de l'alphabet.
Le poète libanais Khalil Gibran disait :
« J'ai appris le silence des loquaces,
la tolérance des intolérants,
la bienveillance des méchants. »
C'est un slogan formidable pour notre époque.
Des démagogues populistes, nous apprendrons
la nécessité de la démocratie ;
des isolationnistes, le besoin d'une solidarité mondiale ;
des tribalistes, nous apprendrons la beauté du cosmopolitisme
et la beauté de la diversité.
J'aimerais vous quitter avec un mot, un seul goût.
Le terme turc « yurt », qui signifie « patrie ».
Il signifie « terre natale ».
Mais curieusement, ce terme signifie aussi :
« la tente » des tribus nomades.
J'aime cette combinaison car elle évoque chez moi
le fait que la terre natale n'a pas besoin d'être ancrée dans un seul endroit.
Elles sont transportables.
On peut les emporter là où on le souhaite.
Je pense que les écrivains, les passeurs d'histoire,
quand le soir approche,
ils ont une seule terre natale,
appelée « Terre d'histoires ».
Le goût de ce mot
est celui de la liberté.
Merci.
(Applaudissement)